Snakes on a Plane was a ridiculous work of
fantasy with no basis in reality….
But as it turns out, a scenario almost exactly
like that once happened over a hundred years
ago on a boat.
While some of the details of the event have
been lost to history, what we know for sure
is that sometime in the closing months of
1889, a ship called the Margaret set sail
from the city of Durban in current day South
Africa helmed by one Captain Sargent.
The Margaret was headed for Boston with a
rather curious cargo that included at least
100 cockatoos, a dozen or so snakes, two crocodiles,
an orangutan, a gorilla and an unconfirmed
numbers of monkeys and parrots.
According to a copy of the Sydney Morning
Herald from April 9, 1890, the animals were
destined for a museum (though it doesn’t
mention what for or which one).
Shortly after setting sail a horde of rats
caused chaos by eating through the meager
grain stores that had been set aside for the
cockatoos and parrots, resulting the deaths
of all but a few of the birds by the end of
the journey.
The crew’s efforts to save the birds were
put on hold when a freak gale knocked over
some boxes, freeing all of the snakes.
At the same time, the crocodiles also managed
to escape and entered into a three way battle
royale with the snakes and rats, effectively
making it so the crew didn’t have safe access
to a large portion of the ship for a reported
five days.
In a bizarre stroke of good fortune, after
all of the snakes and rats were dead, the
lone surviving crocodile was killed when a
second storm hit and knocked over a box of
cargo, crushing the crocodile and once again
making the hold accessible.
But this wasn’t the end of it.
You see, all of the monkeys had escaped and
had taken refuge on the only place they felt
somewhat safe, the ship’s rigging.
Despite the best efforts of the exhausted
crew, they only managed to recapture four
of the monkeys before a combination of storms,
high winds and giant waves swept the remainder
out to sea, never to be seen again.
Now at this point, you’re probably thinking,
surely it’s all over, right?
To which we respond, you forgot about the
gorilla.
Yes, along with having a dozen snakes, two
crocodiles and a slew of monkeys to deal with
on a relatively small ship, the crew also
had to figure out how to convince an angry
gorilla to climb back into the box it had
forced its way out of.
As if that wasn’t bad enough, the gorilla
also somehow managed to get hold of a sturdy
iron bar, which the Wiltshire Gazette reported,
“With this formidable truncheon [the gorilla]
threatened to brain every sailor who came
within range.”
The only positive thing going for the crew
was that the gorilla was still chained to
the floor, though the chain did give it relatively
liberal range.
It reportedly put up an impressive amount
of resistance, injuring almost every member
of the crew as they vainly tried to get it
back in its container.
The worst injury was suffered by the crew’s
cook who was apparently “partially scalped”
by a crushing blow to the temple he failed
to duck.
The gorilla then grabbed the cook, whose life
was only saved via another crew member taking
the opportunity of the gorilla being occupied
to sneak up behind it and wack it over the
head with the blunt end of a hatchet.
The stunned gorilla was then forced back into
its box.
You might be wondering at this point what
happened to the orangutan that was stored
on board.
Well, none of the news reports or other accounts
mention that it survived the trip, so presumably
it either died in the same way the monkeys
did or perhaps was eaten by a crocodile.
In January of 1890, the Margaret limped into
port in Boston, reportedly a great surprise
to the museum staff who’d simply assumed
that the boat had been destroyed by a storm,
since it was so late to arrive.
In the end, the staff who’d been waiting
for their large shipment of animal cargo to
arrive found only four cockatoos, a few monkeys,
and a single gorilla left alive.
When the bemused authorities asked Captain
Sargant what had happened, he simply responded
that between the storms and the animals it
was an experience he’d rather not repeat
and promptly refused to talk about it.
Thankfully for those of us who like a bit
of odd, obscure history, his crew were significantly
less tightlipped and told the story to anyone
who’d listen, leaving us of the 21st century
with the humorous 19th century newspaper accounts
of
the event.